right right to one and we should be live
we should be live let me just make this
the octave thing but I think of what
life I get to the next row this is ready
champ
oh crap expose it well don't close X
okay there we go all right now let's
turn that down even more
I know you don't okay guys so here's
what's happening I better meet this all
right tell me if you can hear me all
right cuz I can save a lot of comments
and they're fairly alive all right so
here's the deal
tell me
second of all second of all this is
basically gonna be like a question
that's a live stream because I'm
obviously leaving to go to Germany face
to the day off tomorrow source obviously
so long the problem with that is that
you guys are really gonna be seeing many
videos for me for the next five weeks
and I hope be nice to just do like a
question-and-answer session with you
guys right here right now
so they're going in bursts again like
based base five disappeared right now
like comments anyway yes are all
questions and I'll try to answer them as
best as I can which is pretty damn good
by the way kiss my best
whoa frickin amazing so we go oh I'm
gonna run with a bad dog happening here
you know in the general Laboratory of
the moratorium yeah I go get some water
as well if it's hang on are you ready to
say in your work at the screen yes
wait for it it's pretty far behind yeah
and look these update like once every
like 10 seconds here we go here yeah
here we go okay um yeah maybe I will
start Twitter grandpa died Monday what
am i doing Germany okay okay two
questions how come I'm going to Germany
what am i doing in Germany I'll answer
them in like five seconds that's going
to get some water
and look at me did we just live longer
but I'm already back there during parts
that you've got a question posed the
question
protip to me okay okay um sure notes
dude it's all back nice I just got back
from a party welcome was that much of a
party it's more of a my farewell party
because it's miss my friends celebrate
it's gonna pack it over the country
because it's just amazing
well no I just want say like some
awesome dumpling place not that you guys
can bet on probably not 35 banks it's
gonna be good if you want to get the
j-bird sorry we're just watching use
expression right now oh okay I'm Izzy
Blaine I'm not playing it anymore okay
no I'm happy I'm happy with this got
recorded into youtube history oh okay um
I want to start answering these
questions so maybe the pop art works I'm
not sure okay what game is you playing
that would be real more thing yeah the
game is realm of the mad God I strain
myself playing I feel like free oh okay
all right
sir um what about how come I'm going to
Germany I have family in Germany okay so
I'm Russian as you guys know you might
not but I'm Russian I was born in
Australia that I put my parents wrong
okay anyway so but Russia's Russia at
the moment is a fairly bad place
no offense to papal living in Russia I'm
watching this right now but um it's it's
it's could be better so my family was
brought up to the Soviet Union broke
they went to two different countries
like Australia is right I'm gonna
disable automatic updates so I kept
using the question to Australia Israel
Germany and I'm just gonna go every like
two years also I usually go and visit my
family in Germany just uh yeah and I
have a bit of a holiday there as well
what is this place what ever been here
before it's just a place you have a
Skype guys question my pants oh but I
just got in and you just closed the
realm oh wait can you get out you can
forget so I'm going to Germany because
my family best I can have a cold I
really don't like things I've did a
level one but I had a good freakin style
I shut off these people want me to
answer that question problem alright um
what am i doing in Germany again how
come I'm going to Germany doing in
Germany the same thing um well I'm
staying to having some fun basically
visiting my family um I might started he
ever drumming when I get back if I have
enough time I mean I just thought sort
of be preparing for the year 12 is
endless but yeah so I will say okay what
got me into Java basically the
frustration of xni studio for C sharp
and the uselessness of Visual Basic got
me into Jolla I I did actually but I
plan to code games for living north I
want to be a filmmaker
so I'm gonna study film in television
when I when I did school when I finished
my finish school their University inside
of film television okay um what came
after that will I be making a multiply
network means orally yes if I don't a 2d
series which will I will definitely
include a networked a multiplayer to DM
yeah off of us for 3d multiplayer if I
do it'll WJ GL and if it gets
vast enough I might get onto that I'm
not sure though I haven't actually done
flawless 3d multiplayer yeah so I don't
know okay hey you could be living in
great slow it's fully about that Rashmi
dad
all right yeah Chanda should I make me
an offer on with the mag or I'll say
using us to count
you use the counts music now to use the
count what does that mean account that
is being used but if he's using an
account that he probably made it like
where's the question should I make an
account or stay using us it's like
almost like us aced like most like the
Bevan right if it was like League of
Legends cuz there's like different
accounts is like a North America one and
you're a paste
you know already done you're applying
clue
yeah I've no idea okay here's my
question I was following your job
tutorials up until website riot
everything was fine when I was 28 you
call the video anyway and said could you
please upload - khutbaat yeah I got the
video for two reasons first of all it
was me trying to fix an hour and that's
look like a while to fix this I just
couldn't find it and the second reason
cutting that was because the video would
be like over an hour long but encoded
know exactly an hour and six is what I
got it
um but I'm not sure a lot of people with
emailed me and not even an email let me
just tweeted me and being like you know
what's up with episode 28 I'm not
actually sure what happened with it like
I'm not sure what I caught it it's gonna
walk with the you guys's and the fact
that I had no idea what might refresh
the bed about that I have no idea what a
cop but um
oh yes yes guests look how these how
these comments people that disbanding
instantly like a people actually going
yep
flag his family well what is it look
it's like the army yeah but why wait is
that your diapers
hey um all right our guest account so I
should he make is what's a guessing I
don't know what a guest account is thing
tbh there's no guessing oh no if you if
you go on all that all you to make a
steam camp for it my page yeah yeah I
know yes thing I was searching for music
calling you mr. Luisi I was yeah and I
bet that I just recorded the game no no
you should okay the way you should play
realm of the mad God has got a stain
make a statement if you don't have a
steam account then make one but you
probably will first thing after during
play around with mad gods drawing that
same work because it can't play the game
unless you do that kidding but um no we
have to do is what you're looking at
already oh you'd gone sir yeah um yeah
so first thing you should do is create a
same account you search for the game on
Steam and you don't like the game on
Steam and then you should then you just
watch the game on Steam and it'll
automatically associate your steam
account with that the rebels manic
account that's how you join use a guest
account I don't even know what that is I
guess account just means it isn't saving
proto so I guess so you get to like
level 20 if y'all get Du Bois and then
you're like oh yeah well as soon as they
stop playing the games gone I'm guessing
that's what happens so no I don't um
yeah it was it what what what's the
problem with episode 20 a nicely I'm an
idea I dunno your emails I just I've
been such a dick to be honest I haven't
actually got about 30 on ready
which I just happen to be bothered
rating makes me feel like a dick but hey
I'm a busy man sort of oh it's cool all
right that's why the span because it
lessens anything like three times yo
you're that light tech guy on you say
him sig you lists saga pissed I own
eyebrows at this guy um I know I know
you sent me like five emails and I
haven't responded to any sorry um
all right I will I will I don't know I'm
just [ __ ] a video
okay hmm what's not work I have water
seriously what's not working I mean it
can't be that fast that you public
policy yourself to try hi okay
I would you definitely have to hit keep
hitting f5 to view the updated comments
this is [ __ ]
okay steam FTW by Nora no no no cut the
audio okay I am
what does I am I the updates on the chat
or slower yeah I have to keep hitting f5
to say that the new answer I said he's
just like I am i boy do you think
recording small PC games normal backup
will be edit with fraps of Camtasia
perhaps even if there aren't get out
tiny they are that 2 by 1 pixel games
then what if I try to make a game what
if I honestly tried to make a game just
for like a livestream or something
legitimately had like the small amount
of like the small smaller resolution as
I can get it do that it'd be like a 30
by 20 pixel game or something that I'm
gonna get all that like it kick your
character would be one pixel big guys
and they say yeah they're on there like
three cubes 10 times
ah you are the blade that guy yeah
um would you ever do a tutorial on an
engine based it again now I'm not sure
if you guys have problems with typing or
something and then ended based game I'm
guessing I'm gonna try and be creative
here and guess there's like a game with
me guessing what you guys are saying in
the end the damn Commerce um
what a contract close your ass so did
your channel 5 you commenting on close
your ass close your eyes
Oh was he from Argentina coughing you're
ruining my life it's all right Scott
Professor Oak is is really show you five
your comments yeah I'm like I'm joking
oh yeah okay um would you okay would you
have a door tutorial or an engine based
game um well I don't honestly the sense
that that comment is making is is
non-existent because games are engine
based what do you mean by an engine gate
okay Matt Matt es en you're gonna have
to explain something more cuz I've no
idea we don't log base yeah well that's
how I guess you said my computer sucks
do it do what do what guys you have to
realize that this isn't actually alive
it's about well it's as life as it gets
15 seconds it's probably about a
15-second delay so when I say something
15 seconds ago I don't remember what I
said
so there's no way of me actually being
like oh yeah I can totally I totally get
what you're saying cuz I don't so when
you say something like do it yeah what
am i doing like you gotta be like dude
this don't do it cuz it is I don't know
what it is but couldn't you just operate
it unlisted it'll take you five minutes
any hours dude okay listen
episode 28 episode 28 Karina's - Oh 28
okay
episode 28 is two months old that has
been deleted from my harddrive about 15
times over sort of activated it 15 times
okay
selling me having the top corners of my
face don't be silent actually talk no no
I can be silent okay um yeah cool um
episode 28 is two months old so I don't
have the footage anymore so I can't
really post it I would if I would
obviously if I could do I like
pineapples yeah do you like pineapple
yeah hope you have lots of kick you out
of my house now pineapples are awesome
especially pineapple and people don't
like but a lot of people don't like up
on the pizza
like I don't it's good because it's like
a suede like it's like a juxtaposition
so yeah I'll all this Jam
shout out to Jamie while or because he's
watching this mr. frost detail it's up
to 15 subscribers and zero views he's a
shaking like I'm a bee bees man
what it's a cheeky mic yeah cuz they can
you know they recognise please say
creation creation oh it's your name oh
you're funny that's it that's of me well
do you only know a job at Naru I know
well html's our programming language I
know
fine arts a shop essentially I nor
definitely include Minister know foreign
languages we got I know English and
Russian if that helps add a bit of
German they'd speak some Russian so you
can pull my community so you want me
like to make a game with an existing
engine I actually talked about this I
don't like using other people's engines
to make games just because I feel
limited by them so otherwise something
like unity like I can't do everything is
possible with it because it's not
essentially if you make something from
scratch you've got complete control over
it if you don't then you don't have to
tell of it to look like people obviously
like it hasn't updated yeah this is the
monstrous comment f5 ball f5 home when
you just a prairie can I please get a
share there like look where the pine
wait maybe SVN did we play with him last
night
I don't know but seriously the pineapple
comment not even in here like an army
chef sister there's oh my god it's
cheeky Mike ah that's good sign
you look really creepy when you glare at
this
lul lul it's fun showing you comment
Jill I have no big ones yet
what does better C++ Java I would say I
would say I would say Java just because
the job is the only problem is that safe
as Paul says memory Lake issues that I
don't like
not that they bother me too much but
simple sauce is just more complex look
like what C++ can do more Java can do
they're identical like there's literally
nothing that you could do in sip I
suppose that you couldn't in Java and
for those of you who say yeah
superfluous both would do it faster nor
say fast boss was virtually the same
speed as Java now back like 10 years ago
yes he was class was awesome
okay so yeah I would say Java just
because my friends just entertaining
himself because he saves the screen was
so what he does now what he does now
when he's not watching the sprint he
could then look at it 15 seconds light
up and see himself doing it it's like a
make me a movie really self-type not
even like let me just log in and you can
sort for a minor okay
oh hi you what's my password I think
it's this but I'm not sure there's a
psychopath but it might look um okay so
yeah I'd say Java just because it's
multi it's cross-platform it's yeah it's
cross platform and it does have memory
issues and it's filling the table and
pretty new Oh Rosalie just go yeah 151
Newman but yeah I'm spurred so many
freaking that adds the friends list I
own his wife or it's like I don't even I
reckon cuz it's loading them look this
is Kate's going file for now I'm not
even a Scrooge e6b TC says look it just
keeps on popping up ignore banana shade
here for game
except that one okay um when did I start
programming 2006 or just kill game is
gonna love that
okay you've been invited to the their
district and flipy bits he's like yes I
meet him unfortunately
yeah but he's sending in the actress
yeah okay
scorpions the bestest sense can i
showing you guys some games by it made
maybe maybe some time i'm not now
concider out without no I've I've only
finished about three or four games to be
honest
oh here we go is what I miss cuz it was
the comments went to cost I applied a
machinima or do I only make money from
them
so any committee room rate this question
did you apply to machinima and do you
only make money from them of the for yo
gana okay maybe I'm gonna have that
makes sense actually you okay um no I
make money for any video any video I
upload that I own the rights to which is
everything your six creeping advice look
at them go down swell when you just do
it if you know Oh do it okay same just
made this option we can just ignore all
invites like that's just like sounds
just like crashing no offense to you
guys well you may get ten friend
requests do I know any of them your nor
friends in common ignore the one broken
common is gonna be my own group so just
the ignore its way that's sorry but
don't wanna say I'm gonna send anything
about your like all best idea right so
ya know um any video I thought how much
I don't like you wanna die so you guys
love too much pads yeah um these mashed
potatoes Curtis okay
you think Tiger is going to win the US
Open this weekend like a would salsa oh
yeah
posing like no no I talk I see if
they've got this Tiger playing golf now
it's pretty cool I in that cosmic like
oh hey mister yeah no no I'm totally
well I don't know I didn't really watch
I actually used okay listen listen to
this cool story bro in London coming up
I I went to like his golden moment like
it was just I thought if I just went to
like his golf like thing because my
grandpa wanted me to when I was like 13
or 14
never played golf before I want it I
literally want hang on hang on
not even kidding right I legitimately Oh
legitimately won this
hang on this is like a bunch of like
testing thank you close Bengals and
actual like there's a tough life with
your very good product placement you
don't like hack into you thankfully my
goals I I want like a bottom which I
never opened because I don't like all
but I felt that was pretty cool so that
was the song conveniently lying
they water this is on my bedroom this in
my office okay
hey mr. Jonas that's crazy hey mr.
churner
when people are gonna be watching this
like not live they just gonna like I
don't even bother doing that okay um
George boom oh you guys didn't slammers
house still not that anyone else is
gonna get this
when are you going to release to be on
disaster when did you stop you say pie
and shade spine James well yeah when did
you start programming 2006 I've answered
this like five times what should be used
to make a look at some West Marion
stress what
typically China exposing crepes and yes
that is in fact the one entirely well
because a Nana's cap as my background is
at the best oh you [ __ ]
oh yeah that's yeah those guys didn't
watch me okay um back to questions
I sell program in 2006 is a bad time to
refresh his comments on can you have my
babies no not followed oh it's like
horse porn that's the best thing what
should be used to make a 3d damage lol
direct pencil the sander OpenGL no our
questions about hey mr. t I've already
asked this question man
um okay one really a real tiger in our
how do I do it here how did I get here
that phrase reminds me of festive maybe
for I can't this I don't even it's
another question yeah no how did like
fat cat say that's that
no I'm guys like horse porn know that
I've seen it what's wanted I wouldn't
know I guess I know that she should dude
when do you plan to solid are you seeing
reoccurring questions like I am want to
read my clients you sexy beast of the
lowest of lows I loves you too much to
light live are you watching UEFA 2004
football none it's our creation
do you want to play football is I'm not
aware that's not possible
can you make videos to show off the
games you have already made um I will
have my baby sit on my mat ESPN I think
he was on lost your dad like anyway I
don't know well like that is he's just
like watching sponsor no no that means
dude is 11 11
everybody making a wish no sorry man 11
12 and I could but say on the stream
hhor-- know what shouts the program I
was drowning in the sea f1 you've said
you said that jerk on my facebook page I
showed it to my friends my friends
thought it was pretty lame and look at
this what's lame what watch how's the
program I was drowning in the sea f1 get
it cuz yeah that's his reaction no no no
that's um okay hello I'm Inc is nothing
I'm just what I'm just wondering where
you are
I'll miss him okay
okay is there an easy way to connect
about collisions in Java without putting
everything in a lesson checking over
tango forever no I'm sorry I can't bye
see you in five minutes
my daddy's angry at me he said he wasn't
why I see the light traffic oh look
you've got some that Sofia yeah that was
from like ages ago which anyway um hang
on let me just finish this
do I hear you yeah don't show that to
this training night you know you know
okay yawn is a little like a little
cutie pie young all right all right no
it's so good
okay um Nora there's no easy way to
calculate collisions of Java don't even
ask me about that just do it again the
way I calculate collisions for 2d games
is I was trying to talk to me last and I
think that is Jamie it's oh oh hello
Mike okay just making sure
um the way I cracked my collisions
patootie games Java is whatever object
you stop doing that whatever object I
have I just may get ready I just make a
square essentially yeah exactly
to get our arms
there's this tall sort of object like
once a minute I think
16 neat comments um okay
sorry what I what I usually do for can
you actually help me a little yeah yeah
um this thing is words out alright grab
the laptop yes hold it off and then I'm
actually going to like take something
that's nor can I unplug the children
yeah and if you actually bring up x-play
you'll be able to say if people can
actually save yep it alright
sorry oh don't drop your nice laptop
alright sorry quickly yeah that's pretty
good
collision plant
no higher isn't oh yeah that's what all
right and I'm get my nose out of the way
here hunter watch okay
sorry collisions for 2d games here's
your game window it's for any good
college irken it's fine yeah you've got
squares you want to calculate clearance
between two squares for example I'm just
assuming that you're making everything
to a square sort of standard you
calculate the center point of the square
by so this is the X&Y
right this is the X&Y this would
obviously this point right here would be
X plus the width and obviously the Y
this would be X plus with y plus height
and this would be X comma y plus hi
right four points on squared you
calculate this point the center point of
the square by adding X plus the height
doesn't don't with divide but you can
anyone say this nor anyway X plus the
the width divided by 2 and then
obviously and then the Y plus the height
divided by three gives you the center
point once you know that you can check
to see if the distance between so if two
squares are colliding then the distance
between their two center points is going
to be less than the distance of this
Plus this into this so in other words
let's just say that out of a square it's
16 I don't know that this distance right
here is 32 pixels and of another square
the distance from the center the radius
of the square the radius of the circle
you say is 32 32 pixels 32 plus 32 is 64
so in other words if the difference
between those two squares is less than
30 then 64 pixels then there is a
collision all right that is how
collision to section
I think that might be people yes I get
out I will in the man put up these
little baby sign I don't have it on this
on my computer
hey look it's still made drawing stuff
in the lab what we'll just BRB yeah babe
that means be right back yeah I'll be
back in a minute
alright I'm back I hope you guys liked
that explanation
now that's 24 new comments it's made to
read okay well what's the what is the
best place to learn Java um best place
to learn Java this guy he's really good
um you should go home for such the
Cherno project that guy
no um best place to learn Java this is
why I like this is why I like this is
why I like having a webcam this I've had
this book for years it's good it's
really good
um one of this particular book for you
is because this is the fourth edition
but these books Java for dummies they're
really good especially if it's thawing
out I still use it as a reference sila
great reference India I realize that :
was probably like it says that comment
is one second ago whereas actually what
probably about 20 minutes ago
um anyway I just shared 24 new comments
and I would find where I finished five
minutes ago
I don't sound impressed am i sounding
depressed do I sound is do I sound
depressed guys so I'm feeling sure why
here we go oh yeah yeah I found it right
open GL give us some arguments
ah it's all been plat for us it's orbits
so is it up until have never seen
results it's cross platform and it
generally it generally gives you a lot
more freedom than direct acts I mean
I've never even did I haven't done
DirectX but I just know that if I can
jealous cross platform man is gently
hello quality he's OpenGL and Adam to
Java so the lost OpenGL is OpenGL is
it's like a like a graphics library
it's basically and it's basically a set
of basically a way for your computer to
talk to your graphics card and tell the
graphics card to render stuff does Frank
so it's it's it's a graphics library I
think that's the proper time
now I know her football is not ours
I know what football is and our football
is well no football
we have Australian football we have
soccer which in Europe of course soccer
is called football I know that I just
spilled water everywhere someone just
said someone spelt it with one or so it
was fought ball and I was pretending to
be you know a bit of a dick and be like
oh what's football but I do you guys
didn't get that something I tell you
guys with um as soon as I get to like
the end of the comments there's like 12
new ones and I'm just like oh good I
finished all the comments enough I'm
gonna end this very it's like 11:30 so
I'm gonna end this for a very 11:30 p.m.
with those okay
something happens to my sashes and they
are still showing tiny squares I tell
you to send me your card but I've done
that in the past and people have sent me
their code and I fixed it and then I go
back to reply to the email and there's
like another two emails with people
sending me that card and I don't have
time to sort through like five to ten
emails a day because it's not just
replying to emails it's actually May
opening project in Eclipse May editing
program it probably takes about 15
minutes to solve it something like as
much as I'd love to provide you guys
with that level of support it's not
happening because I don't have time
unfortunately and don't don't don't
offer to like pay me a bunch of people
have been like you know I'll pay you if
you fix my card no I don't know how to
do that sorry okay
how often do you drink dogs the
companion cube hang on last year last
year I did a last year I did a I did a I
did a course at school a closet school
it's called date aid stands for design
and Technology basically you what you do
in that class is you keep a foliar
essentially of you making something so
this was a light that's sort of like a
thing inside it this is essentially a
light so I didn't finish it
obviously I didn't paint it or anything
but I wanted to make it companion q3
portal just uh just just cause I'm not
sure why
portals obviously an awesome game but
yeah I just made that in yeah I think
can you make opengl st i was gonna okay
this guy called the coding universe
shout out to him the coding universe you
probably have heard of him I'm not sure
kept a makes really nice OpenGL
tutorials but I will stop making them
myself
sir
okay huh not so happen that um okay
sword
yeah oh I will make tours in the future
but fill it for the meantime um you
should go home for lunch decoding
universe they're great okay
it's hilarious
this is a question analysis time it's
just that there's so many questions I'm
still answering questions from like 10
minutes ago because I can't I can't
stay focus that much please explain up
in jail properly OpenGL let me google
that for you the industry send for high
performance graphics ok um neon helium
tutorials and good as well yeah yeah I
mean okay
opengl stands for open graphics library
it is is it open source I think yeah I
think so it's big what a license various
licenses it's a standard specification
defining a cross language multi-platform
API application programming interface
for writing applications and simulating
physics that produce 2d and 3d computer
graphics explain OpenGL
yeah
all right shiny cars
I am in my companion cuber this is like
my office
oh okay guys my set over the place so
this is essentially my setup I've got
the oops
not sure how well you guys will be able
to say it I've got the the black magic
black magic sorry the Razer BlackWidow
Ultimate abyssal 3 edition keyboard and
the rise of Mamba that's like the
docking station for Mouse and it's a
huge huge subwoofer right there and then
I've got my xbox here and it's like
connected to the monitor so everything
is in this room basically and I even got
like some sound equipment here and like
what I should get tall over there and
I'll an electric guitar anyway this is
like mine full-on um where I don't sleep
alright
I'm honestly just gonna go in like a
minute
okay because I have to go sleep cuz I'm
tired yeah
so la lost literally lost round of
questions
binary operators and how do you know
where to use the mean in the game um how
do I write myself how do I rank myself
analyzes the binary thing in a minute
how do i rack myself in programming
awesome amazing or chuck norris you say
guys you say kids there's a rack above
Chuck Norris
it's called rank churner and that's me
no I'm absolutely kidding I probably
write myself as Olsen out of awesome
amazing normal chuck norris no I'm not
I'm not that I wouldn't say I'm that
good
I've only had like three years of Java
so I'm not gonna say that I mean I can
pretty much do anything actually in Java
but I just don't have the experience to
know what the most efficient way of
doing something is so yeah all right
binary operators they come with
experience it's not something that you
can experiment with just because you
need to know how it works like you need
to know that you know you have to shift
red it's red color bits 16 pixels to the
right are 16 pixels 16 on sloths 16
binary 16 bits to the right you need to
know that stuff it's all familiar you
can just experiment with so as for when
to use binary operators Google and just
knowing how things work I mainly use
binary operators for color that's pretty
much it III sometimes use them when I'm
randomizing things or building AI
actually that might be weird but it
works okay it's 11:30 p.m. yes okay last
question very last question am i in
germany now nor I'm not I'm in Australia
so um Melvin
yep that's it okay last question was are
you in Germany now no I'm still an
almond but I will be in Germany two days
three days definitely two days because
Germany's behind me in time all right
thanks for watching guys this video will
get uploaded automatically so yeah
hopefully one crop like a last video did
but yeah see you guys later
let me just anta strain real quick
let me just up and the strain real quick
which I do by live events live now in
that control room okay yeah so once
again thanks for watching and yeah I
know if you want to go if you didn't
catch the whole stream or something
it'll probably it'll get automatically
uploaded in like the next hour or so
I'll be sleeping so I don't know for
well but yeah and you can just use
watching from there so yeah well 48 hour
livestream while I didn't think it would
be that long all right wait see you guys
well